between his incredible aim and friendly
Vibes Tans was one of valoran's
brightest early Stars
or he was embarrassing people on jet
tens played another tax shooter CS go
what the so how good was tens
before Valerie's well his hltv page has
some impressive stats and he had a share
of highlights
okay
holy but against top CS teams well
those numbers drop a bit we do expect
more out of him he's not really been
able to live up to it so far in the pro
league and honestly it's hard to blame
TENS for all of Cloud9 CS go struggles
considering their overall roster
troubles at the time the way I like to
think about it pens struggled in CS so
that he could fly in Valor and God does
he soar this is his world and we're just
living in it